Mr President majority leader
our bipartisan,
bicameral discussions on another
major pandemic rescue package
continued all night and this
morning we're winnowing down
the remaining differences I
believe I can speak for all
sides when I say I hope
and expect to have a final
agreement nailed down
in a matter of hours yesterday
evening our Democratic
colleagues agreed to important
language authored by Senator
Toomey back in March
and the kahrizak Congress funded
several new emergency lending
facilities to be operated
by the Federal Reserve
their purpose was simple
to backstop the basic
foundations of our economy
and prevent any kind of sweeping
financial paralysis our actions
worked the other historic relief
that Congress passed combined
with the existence of these
lending facilities staved off
systemic collapse American
workers and families still need
much more help but a total
financial meltdown never
materialized these new emergency
lending facilities were always
intended to sunset at the end
of this year Senator Toomey
and our Democratic colleagues
have landed on compromise
language that ensures this will
in fact happen.
It also redirects the dormant
money in these accounts toward
the urgent needs of working
Americans and ensures that these
expiring programs cannot be
simply restarted or closed
without another authorization
from Congress all while
preserving both the independence
of the Federal Reserve
and a property proper authority
of Congress yet another example
of good faith bipartisan
collaboration that has defined
our discussions all week at this
point we're down to the last few
differences this time between
struggling Americans
and their major rescue package,
they need and deserve these days
and nights of negotiations have
been encouraging
but our citizens need this
waiting game to be over
yesterday alone another 3,388
of my fellow Kentuckians tested
positive for the coronavirus
the continues to spread
throughout our country thousands
of Americans are being robbed
of their lives on a daily basis
and while the resilience
of the American people have
brought along our economic
recovery recovery faster than
expected it will remain both
insufficient and tenuous until
the vaccines that will end this
fight have been distributed all
across the nation for months,
literally months Senate
Republicans have been calling
for another targeted package
to reopen the job saving
Paycheck Protection Program
extend federal unemployment
benefits fund K through 12
school fund vaccine distribution
and get a lot more help onto
the front lines as fast
as possible I'm relieved that we
appear to be just hours away
from legislation that will
finally do that when we get this
done Congress will not deserve
any special praise not with this
relief having waited until late
December and not with some
of our Democratic colleagues
openly saying the reason they
finally changed their tune was
they finally got
a President-elect of their own
party when we finalize this
measure and pass it Congress
will
all have done our job we will
have finally done our duty
and getting more relief to those
who need it most let's make
today the day we join together
put differences aside
and finally get it done.